les
singes ne valent pas
non vous savez ce qui est inquiétant
avec eux ils ont besoin ni de courant ni
de lumière ni de chaleur rien c'est ça
leur avantage c'est ce qui les rend plus
fort nous avons tous les deux une
famille tu veux protéger la tienne je
veux protéger la mienne c'est notre
seule chance de vivre en
paix est-ce que tu comprends vont se
retourner contre
toi sont
desê C c'est ta maison ici qui cétait un
homme bon comme toi
c
hum plus que
s des
peut-tre
tu veux boire un
coup attends dou doucement
doucement César est le seul à pouvoir
arrêter ça ils ne veulent pas la guerre
et moi je veux sauver
l'humanité
[Musique]
César